we welcome you back to cbs this morning
the withdrawal of u.s troops from
afghanistan reached a major milestone
this morning
the last american troops left bagram air
base that's the main u.s facility in
afghanistan
the military used this airfield to wage
war for nearly two decades
now this comes amid growing concern
about americans being left behind
mark freyrix has been missing since
january of 2020
after being kidnapped in kabul charlie
daggett is in kabul covering the u.s
pull out
charlie good morning to you what can you
tell us about this case
well good morning to you gail you know
bagram is a big deal the us military
presence here is dwindling by the day
and now mark's family is terrified that
he's going to be abandoned
and forgotten the clock is ticking for
mark frerichs
as u.s soldiers pack up and head home
i want the troops to come home to their
families just like i want my brother to
come home
to his family the navy veteran and civil
engineer from lombard illinois
was kidnapped in kabul in january last
year after going to a meeting to discuss
a project
now his sister charlene and her husband
chris are
begging the white house for help what do
you say to president biden
i want to say to president biden that
you're well aware of my brother you know
my brother's situation
are you doing every effort that you can
to get my brother home
like you would if you were your own
brother
but getting him home may get tougher
without u.s
troops providing the intelligence to
pinpoint his whereabouts
or the leverage to mount a rescue
operation or negotiate a release
chris miller is the former senior
director of the national security
council in charge of hostages
i strongly feel mark is a prisoner of
war prisoner swaps
are as old as the dawn of you know
warfare it's completely legal and it's
completely appropriate
and i think there might be an
opportunity there he says
president ashraf ghani has plenty of
taliban prisoners with which to cut a
deal
charlene says her brother's nickname is
magic mark
a talent he even shared here in
afghanistan
he's been a magician since he's three
years old
and he can pull a rabbit out of a hat
and where he comes up with these
these doves that he pulls out of his
shirt and stuff it's just
amazing and not a day goes by that she
doesn't think about the moment she gets
word
that mark is coming home when they give
me that phone call
and tell me that they found mark and
he's on a plane
you're gonna go meet up with them and i
would give him the biggest hug when i
see him
and i don't think i want to let go
president ghani said mark's name didn't
even come up
when he met with president biden at the
white house last week charlene said she
tried to meet with
president trump and with president biden
both men declined
tony it's an agonizing situation for
that family charlie dagetta in
afghanistan charlie thank you very much
the family's saying hey you guys are
leaving the country don't forget about
some unfinished business
and to hear there was no conversation
yeah well the fact that we did the story
hopefully somebody is listening and can
do something about it
you can tell agonizing is a word what
they're going through right now